we're on the brink of war with China for
various reasons I hope we make it to
2050. the demographics is as I describe
it and by the way them losing doesn't
make us winning so I think you're in the
part of the cycle where you've had the
tightening and the dominoes are
beginning to fall and I think that
that's going to produce more problems
the most important thing is to have this
basic well-diversified portfolio is
important
two years ago you made some predictions
about the future for America and the
global economy how accurate do you think
you've been
uncomfortably accurate given the whole
picture you know um
it's like watching the movie for over
and over again
um maybe I should explain
uh
for about 55 years I've been a global
macro investor and I learned that many
of the things that surprised me never
happened in my lifetime before so when I
would see certain things happen that
were like that I would go back in
history and study uh prior periods
studying for example the Great
Depression allowed us to anticipate the
financial crisis in 2008 anyway there
are three big things that I observed
happening
that didn't happen in our lifetimes but
happened during the 1930 to 45 period
and they are
the creation of enormous amounts of debt
and the printing of money to pay for
those debts and it having its economic
effects on inflation and growth
the second is internal conflicts
um over the largest wealth gaps we had
since then values gaps
and the rise of populism of the right
and the left
those conflicts again largest since that
1930 to 45 period and then the rise of a
great power uh producing a great Powers
conflict internationally
um with the rise of China as a great
power uh challenging the United States
and uh with Russia so the great power
conflict that also is the uh most that
that's happened since uh the Great
Depression so because those three things
are happening now and
um I didn't study them
um I went back and I needed to study the
Cycles these what's happened over longer
periods of time so I studied the last
500 years because these big Cycles uh
take about 75 years and give or take
about 50. so
um and um you know like the rise in
decline of the British Empire the rising
decline of the Dead
and that Dynamic I shared
um in the book and I also shared it in
an animated video uh which is called the
changing World Order
um and that creates a path now it's not
just because they repeat in this way but
one can see the cause effect
relationships that are happening and um
so that has pretty much transpired
according to script we can get into
those pieces but I'd say those are the
three main ones there were two others
that had big effect that I paid more
attention to
um that I'll mention one was
um acts of nature in the form of
droughts floods and pandemics they were
very disruptive when they happened
killed more people and uh toppled more
Empires and or Waters than others and
then also of course over a period of
time there's learning and producing new
technologies that raises living
standards you know it's raised per
capita income life expectancy and so on
and so for those five flat factors try
transpire in ways that we've seen before
to create this big cycle and it's uh if
we can look at the cause effect
relationships
um that's what I want to pass along
because I'm 74 years old and I'm in a
phase in my life that I want to pass
along the things that are of value and I
think this is an important thing but yes
it's transpiring according to script
Cassandra yet again unfortunately what
do you think is the likelihood of the
Meltdown of the dollar is America going
to be wiped out at some point soon I
don't want um histrionics you know just
I don't want to
um overdo it and I also don't want to
just jump to conclusions my goal here is
to show people
how the Machine Works the cause effect
relationship so I'm going to answer your
question by explaining certain things
um
the dollar is
um is held by countries in the form of
debt in other words when you say I'm
holding the dollar
um you're holding a dead instrument
and when we have a a problem with the
dead instrument a few problems with it
holding that instruments
um those problems are that first of all
as a result of what the United States
was in the world the largest trading
country
um the dominant Empire and so on there's
been a a huge accumulation of dollar
denominated debt and dollars therefore
and there's also been
um a lot of deficits that had to be
funded which happens by selling dollar
denominated debt which a lot of
foreigners and Banks and others bought
and so they have a lot of dollar
denominated debt now
um if you're a creditor meaning an owner
of dollar denominated debt you need to
have an interest rate that is high
enough to the more than compensate you
for inflation
and so
um the production now of a lot more debt
and and them having a lot of debt and
then also sanctions internationally
which means freezing dollar denominated
debt all have created a reduction in the
demand for dollar denominated debt
there's also you know concerns in the
world about some of the things that are
going on in the United States and that's
reduced to that as a result of that
um you're seeing more transactions take
place in other currencies
um and if they trade take place in other
currencies then others want to save in
those other currencies
um because that's how they pay for it so
if you want to save and what you pay for
you save more in it and less in dollars
and so that's the dynamic that is
reducing the demand for dollars and
dollar debt at the same time as the
supply of it keeps coming because we
have large deficits
so the underlying value that those
dollars uh represent isn't increasing
but the number of dollars spread across
that is
yeah so that there's a supply demand
issue that Supply demand issue by the
way also exists in European currencies
okay they have too much debt and their
Finance the same way and Japanese
currencies and so what you're seeing is
the movement
all that weight of money and debt is
causing prices to go up inflation
and that's also being worsened
by the supply chain
deteriorations that are due to the
international conflict so for example
um in case of let's say China and the
United States
um and other countries as they prepare
for the possibility of War they want to
be self-sufficient
and so
um as a result they work on being
self-sufficient more than integrated and
efficient and so
um that Dynamic is playing an important
role too
what do you think the next few years
have got in store for us
um
well
um I'm going to take all three of those
influences and answer it because they're
all related
the um there's a
uh business cycle or a short-term debt
cycle I call it
um that you know sort of recession to
recession and the way it works is you
have a recession in Weak economy central
banks
um stimulate credit growth credit gives
you buying power you go out and buy the
economy picks up
um and then that continues until you
start to have inflation then they
tighten monetary policy and then it uh
and then the economy weakens and it goes
into the next recession
since 1945 when the New World Order
began in other words we had the currency
and also the American World Order
beginning in that we've had 12 and a
half of those Cycles we are they've
typically last about seven years give or
take about three and so we are now about
halfway through this cycle in which they
um
you know you they did the stimulation
inflation Rises they tighten monetary
policy and we're in the phase of the
cycle where there's going to be then the
cracks occur occurring and the negative
um impact on economic activity and the
like and it's going to be more difficult
than normal because there's so much debt
outstanding and we're you know what we
just talked about so that is likely
um to happen over let's say the next
year and year and a half which means
that it will take us in through the
elections and what we have is a
situation where the second of those
influences the internal conflict
influence is bad and you have a lot of
populism so populists are people who
will fight to win at all cost they're
not calm compromisers you know I will
fight and I will win for you and the
rules be damned you know compromising be
damned and um so you're going to have a
political situation in terms of you know
that kind of environment it's a bad time
for that but it'll end up paying an
impact on the um on the nature of the
elections I think and then you have
um the international conflict we are
much closer to
um
a dead conflict a war of of sorts either
a sanctions an economic war or even
possibly a military war with China and
because of the politics also that that
will be pushing its limits too because
there are um the one thing that most
Americans are united on in both
Democrats and Republicans are united on
is anti-china and
um as a result
um you know and they all want a strong
man or woman strong person uh on that
and so I think you're going to see
pushing of the limits there and that
becomes a dangerous set of circumstances
so I think that
um if we take the next uh you know let's
call it one two three years I think that
those are going to be uh riskier years
I spoke to an evolutionary psychologist
and an evolutionary Anthropologist a
little while ago on the show and they
were teaching me about the values and
the type of characteristics that
ancestral tribes would have preferred in
leaders at different states and in times
of Warfare more dominant leaders were
the ones that were preferred in times of
Peace more prestigious leaders were the
ones that were preferred makes complete
sense if you are facing a scary tribe
from the other Valley you want someone
that's going to stand firm and is going
to not take any and they're going
to go for it when times of peace that
person becomes a bit tyrannical it's a
little bit too much energy when there's
not anybody else to fight and it's so
funny how you see this just same Dynamic
to me it seems play out no matter how
big the populations get it's essentially
the same physics that's right it's it's
happened repeatedly if you're if you're
in a war what you want is
um the commander and everybody you know
to goddamn follow the instructions and
just do what you're told
and you know it's not like we're going
to sit there and argue debate and and so
on so what you see and is the breakdowns
and particularly you see the breakdowns
in
um also when they're at odds there's a
lot more to argue about
um like now the populace of the left and
the populace of the right and so in the
1930s you saw four democracies become
dictatorships choose to become
dictatorships they had parliaments that
chose to become dictatorships Germany
Italy Spain and Japan chose that because
in order to fight yeah that's what you
need and not your Anthropologist friends
are
um right on that yeah the consolidating
power in an attempt to try and be able
to enact more change more easily it's
not we haven't got time we haven't got
time to get this across the line
diplomatically we haven't got time to
get everybody on the same page we'll
have one person who knows what they're
doing and they'll Push It Forward one
one thing that I and another thing
that's common is um the foreign enemy
when you have
um a situation where you have internal
dispute
um
um it's very very common
to try to bring the country together get
support by The Leader by having the
common enemy you know and so we'll all
rally around you know the leader and you
could see you know it was like um you
know when 9 11 happened and you know the
president
um you know Bush gets a standing ovation
and we're all behind you in that fight
and so that's yeah that's Timeless and
Universal Dynamic if you can't bond
yourselves together overshed love of an
in-group shed hatred of an out group is
a close enough proxy I suppose for that
interim was there anything um
over the last two years that you didn't
anticipate or is there anything
particularly unique about the situation
that we're in now every what is it uh
every time people say it's going to be
different this time is there anything
that could make things different this
time or was there anything that you've
been surprised by
um you know by and large I haven't been
surprised by I mean I didn't anticipate
that we were going to have the war with
Russia
um so that um but I did anticipate that
we were likely you know headed in a
war-like environment it's very much fell
with
um as expected there
um the economic and the financial very
much is the same
um so I'd have to uh uh you know by and
large almost exactly it's transpired the
way described and that's why again look
I I did the video for free on YouTube
um the changing World Order
um what I'm trying to do is to just pass
it along for people's consideration to
understand the cause effect relationship
that goes there but yes it's
unfortunately going according to script
that doesn't mean it's destined
okay but it's difficult to take off
track
um what do I mean by that
um
each stage
is
then The Logical consequence of the
stage that preceded it so let's take the
existing situation
the United States has a lot of debt
and it has deficits
so it has to sell debt now if you say
and others are holding debt
and if you say how do you get healthy
um you have to
spend less than you
earn
to get to not borrow money and get
financially strong
that's difficult and particularly when
you have a lot of debt because you have
to take a portion of your income and you
have to pay the debt and also you're
living in spending more than you're
earning and so how do you Rectify that
what cut spending I mean it's very
difficult to cut spending or raise
income that's not easy so Ray cut
spending
um what do you cut okay so we're living
in a world now where
um policy makers don't think how much
money do I have to spend and what should
I prioritize it on they think
um how much money
um you know how much money do I need to
spend without regard to how much they
have and then they go spend it and then
they have deficits that
um central banks can print it's just
like the same as individuals they have
the deficit but but in their case they
have the capacity to print the money to
pay the deficit so um it's not easy to
fix the financial problem
um the internal problem you know what
it's like can you get people to come
together
to you know say this is a common
problem let's have the left and the
right and people very difficult people
have big differences in values and
conditions and so
um
it's very difficult to bring them
together to deal with the problems and
the same is true internationally you
know easier said than done
so
um given that Dynamic there is then the
stages and so it's pretty clear normally
what comes next
given all of these changes what do you
think people can do to best prepare
themselves financially for the next few
years
well
I think that
um in Saving
um let's let's talk about that
um
there is I I think of savings in tears
the first tier is to secure your
well-being tone a portfolio
of assets that are going to secure your
well-being
and then after you have that taken care
of then you can go to the next level
take more risk and so on
um that well being that purchasing power
has to be viewed in terms of inflation
adjusted dollars you know if you're
holding
um a debt instrument and you know a cash
paying instrument and it gives you a two
percent interest and you have a five or
six percent inflation you lose money at
three percent a year so you have to look
at that in real dollars and you have to
hold that portfolio in a way that is
balanced to any kind of economic
environment
and then the way I do it and I you know
I I stood I remember you know I didn't
have anything and then I started to
acquire uh money and I start to think
okay how much how many weeks do I have
months do I have
or years that I'm financially safe and
what do I hold it in so and then you
know once you got that taken care of you
can go beyond it and um and I wanted it
in a very well balanced portfolio that
that type of portfolio that does equally
well no matter what happens
um I can explain that a little bit more
if you want that'd be good okay
um
there are basically two big influences
on markets
um
the growth rate and the inflation rate
um like if you know
that
um
growth is going to be
faster than expected
and
inflation is going to be higher than
expected
you know you know that bonds are going
to go down
and vice versa
so the way I I give that as an example
um it so the way I look at it is there
are those two big influences and then
they can so I four environments and each
one of them can go up or down so there
are four
quadrants that I think of
rise in growth falling growth Rising
inflation and falling inflation
and I want to have a portfolio that will
be 25 percent of my risk in each one of
those so that I don't have any bias
and so I pick the assets that are going
to do well in each of those four
quadrants and I hold them in a balanced
way
and I've tested that you know going back
actually to 1900 and so on and you'll
maintain you'll actually increase your
buying power
um and so it um you know that's the kind
of thing that I think in the beginning
then you have to also make provision for
you know taxes to some extent so I say
whatever that amount of money is
I want twice as that so in case it goes
in half
and I want to build a portfolio that
looks like that
um for you know I don't know X number of
years that I have that and that's the
safe savings and then when I go beyond
that then I'll take more uh risk but I
think that being safe
particularly in this kind of an
environment is important and I would
take a perspective of how to do that
that's uh like the one I'm just
describing
what would be an example of an
investment for each of those four
quadrants
well I'm worried that we're going to
take a long time to explain it I've
explained it
uh elsewhere but let me give an example
I'll I'll take it um
like
if growth so there's these four
quadrants growth and inflation
if if growth is less expense less than
expected and inflation's less expected
you would like to own bonds
okay if it's higher than expected
you would not want to own bonds
okay if if inflation
is higher than expected you would want
to own assets such as
Commodities and gold
and inflation index bonds
um
if growth
is faster than expected
particularly if inflation is less than
expected you'd want to own stocks
so you get the idea
one of the things that you brought up
earlier on was the changing internal
structure this is driven by a number of
factors but one of them being increasing
wealth inequality
at the moment it seems like there is a
decline in praising work ethic
especially in the US
do you think that that is a symptom or a
cause of what we're seeing at the moment
well I think the
I'm referring to the let's say the
wealth Gap
um
I think that there's a
it's a there's a lot of
um particularly unproductive people
um for example
um for various reasons but I I live in
the state of Connecticut and my wife
tries to help
um
students in the poorest neighborhoods
that have the worst conditions and I'll
give you
um this example I
the state of Connecticut is usually
number one two or three in the richest
state in the country but 22 percent out
of the last survey it's actually higher
than this 22 percent of the high school
students in Connecticut have either
dropped out of high school or are have
absentee rates of greater than 25
percent in our failing classes and
there's a great deal of poverty and the
breakup of the families and and the
guidance there's a cycle that takes
place and so you're seeing
um the general competitive education
levels that can
conditions um in the in Connecticut
uh so we operate philanthropically and
I'll give you an example
um there was covet and the kids have to
get educated
and sixty thousand kids uh didn't have
computers or connectivity
and
no government was going to do anything
about it so you know we had to buy 60
000 computers to give it to kids in
order for them to have education well
this this and there's hunger and there's
poverty and there's drugs
um I lit it's it's how the educational
system is funded
um education is a state issue by the
Constitution
and then within a state it's a tax
typically within a state it's a tax
District issue so I live in Greenwich
Connecticut which is relatively that's a
real it's a rich uh sit down and the
public education gets about twenty four
thousand dollars per student last number
I looked it's probably higher than that
now gets twenty four thousand dollars a
student up on the road at Bridgeport
Connecticut 10 minutes up the road they
get fourteen thousand dollars a student
because there's no tax base
and
um and they need it more they need more
money because you know the expenses of
raising a kid are are you also have to
get them the computer you've got to get
them the you know the food the clothes
all of those things and they have less
food less clothes on all those things so
um
and well but in any case what you can
see is the education test scores and
measures of how we're doing in education
relative to other countries uh have
declined so part of it is uh education
and circumstances part of it is drugs
part of it is
um you know there are lots of parts of
it and then there's
um a certain element of it which uh
let's say because of covid or other
reasons
um that people have moved around and and
say you know I don't have to work as
hard anymore so you know just for
example the change in the attitudes of
restaurant workers you know okay I can I
found another
a way to live and so on and that's
playing a role
um of course also
people
um as the Baby Boomers are older
um you know they drop out of it or they
want to retire earlier and they do
so there are a number of factors that
affect
um
you know the
this kind of
set of circumstances the bit the wealth
Gap
is very much due
to a self
reinforcing cycle in which if you earn a
lot of money
you can afford to take care of your kids
education you can raise them in a better
way
um if you don't earn a lot of money
you don't have that privilege
so and you know it
so all through history
um during those such times wealth gaps
have increased
so you look at the cycles
um
you have a new you know like a new world
order like in the 1850s you know you
have the Civil War and then you have
that and then you have new technologies
and inventing you have the Industrial
Revolution take place and things go
great but uh what it does is it also
increases the wealth Gap some people
make a lot of money others don't and it
also increases the level of indebtedness
and you make the turn of the century you
there's then you see big conflicts over
wealth you have the
um Panic of 1907 and so what you see is
the Industrial Revolution
turns into What's called the Gilded Age
in which there are very rich decadent
um you know
while there's poverty and you know in
the early turn of the century
um they're living people are living very
very lavishly very decadently at the
same time as their you know sweatshops
and all of that and then there's kind of
a revolutionary reaction to that so
these things happen over and over again
for the same reasons
what would you tell young people then at
the moment what advice would you give
them
um
well
um first of all
uh learn
learn how
I'd say a few things
first know your nature everyone has a
different nature a way a pull what's
their pull toward
um
I created a personality profile test
called principles you it's I put it
online for free and it tells you a lot
about you know what your nature is and
it also shows if you uh if you take the
test and you do and you put somebody
else's in they take the test it'll tell
you about your relationship so you want
to know what your nature is what your
pull is going for and then you go
through your journey of learning
experiences that you know has its ups
and downs and you know you learn you
have your uh you know your painful
experiences but I have a principle pain
plus reflection equals progress you
learn you get that and um and then to
have perspective
to understand
um that all of these things
events transpire you know know the whole
cycle see the whole thing gain
perspective and understand where you are
in the cycle
understand where you are in the life
cycle there's a life cycle
um
you know from birth to death and not say
it on average it lasts about 80 years
and you know that at different parts in
that cycle certain certain things are
going to happen you're going to you know
um
first third of it you're going to be
dependent on others and you're learning
second third of it
um you're going to be independent of
your parents and so on and you're going
to be others will become dependent on
you and you're working to be successful
at the various ages you you get married
you have kids you all of these Cycles
there's a life cycle that happens over
and over again and then there are these
other Cycles these cycles of
um you know
um you know let's call it almost from
from war to war
um
um whether that's a internal War to
changes the internal order or an
external War changes the external order
and there's a cycle that has to do with
a debt cycle and those others and um and
you you and you have to know what those
Cycles are like and kind of where you
are in those cycles and you navigate it
at all I mean the main thing you know is
be strong smart capable and adaptable
but uh that's why I put out these
um you know videos and books to try to
help people understand that you
mentioned one of the common life
landmarks that people get to is having
kids and getting married at the moment
especially in the west but also even
more so in Asia birth rates are falling
through the floor we've got 0.78 I think
in South Korea we've got just around
about one in Japan China also looking
really bad at the moment
what how concerned are you about current
population decline
and future demographics
well it's it's a it's a real burden uh
and also depending on where it is it's a
a real burden
um because the young have to take care
of the old
um so
let's say for example in China
um that with the one child policy
a married couple has four old adults
that they have to take care of there's
not an adequate social program
um and that takes uh time and money
um and it makes it you know a a great
burden makes productivity a problem and
so
um you see you know like you say you
know you see this
um you know that that that is a these
are burdens costs because the those who
need taking care of
um and are not earning money uh need
um you know those resources and it's and
it's sapping
um you know one hopes
that productivity
increases faster than
this burden and that but then it
requires you you have to if you raise
that you have to then divide the pie
well
so it's uh yeah it's um demographics is
a burden
you are maybe alluding that to stuff
like AI uh robots robotized workforces
assisting in terms of getting more juice
out of the smaller demographics that we
do have
and the potential gains of that accruing
to a small number of people that own
that organization you need a relatively
small group to be able to I don't know
how many people are in the open AI
company but something tells me it's a
significantly smaller number than the
amount of impact that it's had and is
probably going to have right so that's
exactly right so if you if the society
as a whole can do that what it will do
is it'll naturally make the people who
some people very rich and some people
very poor
but it can raise productivity enough
that
um it can raise Livingstone let's just
imagine robots always work there and you
don't have to have people in doing the
jobs
um then what you can have then what you
have to deal with is how do you
redistribute the wealth and opportunity
because as I say it'll be concentrated
in some and others will lose jobs and
um there's more productivity for the
whole but you have a distribution issue
are you familiar with Nicholas ebastad
do you know him he wrote men without
work
no he came on the show he came on the
show last week I think he'd be really
interested the book's very very short
and he's discovered this
odd cohort of men that are lurking
inside of the unemployment statistics
the seven million men aged 22 to 55 in
the US who aren't working and aren't
looking for work only 10 of that number
are students from the remaining 6.7
million about 2 000 hours is the average
amount of time that they spend watching
screens and 50 of that time on average
is spent whilst on either prescription
medication or weed recreational drugs
and two-thirds of those men are living
in homes that claim at least one
disability benefit so basically lurking
inside of the low unemployment numbers
is this cohort of prime working age men
who don't have a job and don't want a
job either
one of one of the potential Downstream
implications for that is what does this
mean for Universal basic income that if
these men are able to be supported by
social welfare
but they're not they're not going out
and enacting poetry staring up at the
stars you know speaking their truth
forward and dealing with the existential
pain of living in a good way
this doesn't seem like they're
flourishing particularly and given the
automation that's potentially coming
down the pike I wonder what that means
well I think you paint or he paints an
accurate picture and obviously and it's
not good you know
um my as my wife was describing one
shoes uh dealing with uh that population
now it's very common for kids to come to
school high
and you know then they have what ages
oh young ages
you know
10.
wow okay well marijuana is readily
available
and um so yeah we have a number of these
issues
we've brought China up a couple of times
and I think based on what I know about
your work the conflict between the USA
and China uh as China the ascending new
power that may be overtaking the USA
however we do have this perhaps uh
unprecedented demographic collapse that
China's facing the best predictions that
I've seen suggest that it's going to go
from about 1.1 to 1.2 billion now to
about 650 to 700 million by 2050. so
it's pretty much getting chopped in half
does that uh change the way that uh the
world orders change moving forward
uh I think the main thing with China
right now is um you know we're on the
brink of war with China for various
reasons
um you know like
um I hope we make it to 2050.
um
foreign
so um yeah the demographics as is as I
describe it
um and by the way them losing doesn't
make us winning
um just so we're look look at that you
know
we hope everyone gets better
um
and the world economy we hope everybody
has a better way
um nobody everybody loses in wars and so
um
you know that's their set of
circumstances and it'll be what it'll be
I think the most important thing is how
do we deal with our circumstances you
know how do we become strong and healthy
financially healthy Health productivity
healthy and so on so
um yeah that we could talk about the
demographic problem in in China
um which is just what we talked about
before in terms of you know there's
Robotics and productivity and all that
make up for that I don't know but um I
really think we're projecting too much
on the outside world okay what do we do
with China what of what relevance well
we trade with China
we don't have to go to a military war
with China I mean let's why would we we
shouldn't do that
um you know
um
and um and then if that's the case
you know what's the problem with them
growing you know you know okay but
there's not it's not very much
you know okay let them grow and invent
and let us grow and invent and share the
inventions that would be good
um but the problems that we're facing
are pretty much our own problems
the things we're talking about and the
breakdown of infrastructure and you know
all of that so really
um I think we should focus on that and
you know maybe they're demographic
Graphics is a big burden or not you know
they have other big burdens too we all
do but let's focus on how we can be as
good as we can be
yeah as opposed to presuming that this
is zero-sum game is China
finds life harder therefore America
finds life easier that doesn't work yeah
I understand
um you might have seen the restrict act
which was brought up recently it's
lining up a potential ban for different
types of online services and it seems
like one of the potential bases for
Banning Tick Tock from America which
again to me just
um further embeds this them and us China
is enemy if we can remove that influence
from the West as much as possible then
we are going to end up in a better
situation
well that's the dynamic yes
what do you think about the fed's
messaging about this soft Landing thing
is that possible like historically I
don't think it's it's really happened
but do they have enough control over the
economy to be able to make this work
the big issue is that um
a lot of debt was created a lot of it is
government debt but it is also corporate
to a less extent household debt
um
uh um
so
um if you look at the Silicon Valley
Valley Bank issue
um it's not so much their issue as much
as a worldwide issue and what happened
is that you know what's a bank a bank
takes in deposits
um
and then it takes that money and it
invests it in things and so they bought
a lot of government bonds
that had a higher yield than they were
paying out in the deposits there's a
tightness of monetary policy and those
yields went up and the bonds went down
in value
and then the amount they have to pay out
went up in value
and so they went broke and that is
happening all over that happens not only
through Banks Banks as a whole did a lot
of that but
um insurance companies and so on all
around the world same sort of thing
happened in Europe same sort of thing
happened with Japanese on companies even
buying US dollar bonds a lot and um and
so you have
um if you were to Mark those to Market
you would have a a terrible calamity
um but what's going to likely happen is
they don't want any more of those bonds
and we're going to have to sell more
bonds because we're going to have a
deficit so when you have a deficit you
have to pay for it through selling debt
and there's a lesser demand for that
debt
and um I think that that creates
um you know a problem in which either
interest rates go up or the Federal
Reserves got to come in and print and
this is a problem that exists also in
Europe with the European Central Bank
the bank of Japan all of them so that's
where that's where we are
um and it has knocked on effects it's
like dominoes that fall
so it will produce less credit
and as it produces less credit less less
demand less less credit
that'll produce less spending it'll come
in certain parts of the economy
for example commercial real estate
um for example
um
venture capital and private equity for
example
um low-grade uh bonds where they have it
heavily indebted con company and the
interest rate goes up a lot and that
causes problems so I think you're in the
part of the cycle
where you've had the tightening and then
the dominoes are beginning to fall and I
think that that's going to produce
um more uh more problems so I think when
it comes down to it there's just too
much debt and and we're adding it to it
too quickly and so it's going to
um either that debt will be paid off
with hard money in which case there's
not much Printing and so on or it'll be
paid off with
um printing a lot of money to make it
easier to pay off I think in the end
it'll it's always the case that they
print a lot of money in and make it
easier to pay off but you have the
reduced value of money
so that's how it looks to me and you'll
have probably a stagflation environment
and because you have that Dynamic going
on at the same time as you have supply
chain disruptions because of the
geopolitical
um I think it's going to be a difficult
environment
let's say that we do hit quite an
aggressive recession
what are some of the ways that people
could even look to benefit
financially from that happening are
there any things that individuals can do
um
the most important thing as I say
is to have this basic well Diversified
and you know there's some assets and and
think about different you know a small
percentage of your money even in asset
like gold or or and diversification for
countries you know to just to create a
diversified portfolio is important
one of the things that did occur you
mentioned uh Silicon Valley Bank that
there was a big bump in terms of Bitcoin
into the cryptocurrencies around about
that time and it seemed like one of the
first periods where people genuinely saw
crypto as a store of value as a way to
just I I need to put my money somewhere
that I feel is safe and given the last
18 months of what's happened with crypto
considering that as that's the place I'm
going to store my Assets in order for it
to be safe I think said quite a lot
about how people sort of perceived the
state of the dollar and the security of
Banks and stuff at the moment
what what's the role of Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency in a the current economy
in your in your eyes
um I think
um
cryptocurrency or Bitcoin
um doesn't move in a reliable way
related to almost anything it's uh you
know moves up and down because of
um this mood and that move and mood
um and
um unlike gold let's say I I would
prefer gold and and I would prefer
crypto for various reasons crypto
um
it's very easy to track the owners and
transactions in it it's not liked by the
government
um it's
um it doesn't move in a way that's
consistent with you know kind of any of
the environments and it's a fairly and
it's a small asset class
um you know we talk a lot more about it
but its size is about you know 30
percent of the size of Microsoft and
Microsoft is one stock among many stocks
so uh it's given probably a lot more
attention
um I don't know uh you know who who
knows maybe you know there's some
element of it I don't understand why
people are more inclined to go to
bitcoin than gold
um if you look internationally
um gold is uh for central banks the
third highest Reserve asset first is
dollars then Euros then gold then uh
Japanese Yen
um and Central Bankers are buying gold
and they're not buying
um bonds and um and so and it's you know
Timeless and Universal it's been there
so um but
um you know
um so I'm not
I'm not a big
fan of it as I've said before
um you know having a little bit I have a
little bit of it but if you have a
little bit of it you have to
um think about those things and you know
like I said you know you have to be
prepared for it to fall a lot you know
if it goes down 80 or something but that
limits the amount that you can have in
it so I don't know it's um I don't think
a lot of Bitcoin I think what's
interesting there is
holding crypto essentially has a
cognitive load on you
using it as somewhere that you're using
for investment as a store of value to
just put assets that you've got
it's almost that there is a price that
you pay because of the volatility but
the price that you pay is with your own
sanity
with regards to that
um which is something that I hadn't
quite considered there are less sanity
sapping forms of investment yeah that's
a that's a good way to do you know what
I mean
I've seen
so many people you know I've seen people
get very rich and I've seen people get
very broke with it I have friends in
both camps yeah
so you know we've spoken about today
this very
quickly changing highly volatile
environment that we're in whether that
be socioculturally politically globally
locally
financially
where should people go
in order to find
um some solace in this given the fact
that it is difficult it's difficult to
exist in this world
um
go to
go to places or spend time
where there's not as much of this junk
going on you know um
I mean first of all I think recognize
let's let's go to some of the basics
um
what do you really need
um you know you need a bed to sleep in
you need food to eat
um
um most
depressions most people remain employed
most wars most people don't get die or
get in injured
um
uh so
um you know let's put let's calm down
and put all this in place bit let's be
in places where there's
um
you know goodness and Harmony and Beauty
you know maybe spend more time in nature
or you know you go out there and
um I'd like to meditate meditate is
meditation has had a big effect on me so
um yeah
um
don't get all stressed about it you know
navigate it well
um and you know enjoy life enjoy those
things and I think that that's
you know that I think that's most
important what would you say to the
people that say how am I expected to
enjoy life when there's all of this
chaos going on there's so many bad news
stories and headlines and what about the
financial collapse
well um first of all
if it's really having that impact on you
don't get so hung up on the financial
stories and you don't don't watch the
television or something you know go out
for a nice walk and in the nature like
all that story you don't really need all
that story Okay now what's going to
happen to you like I say
um you know don't get so hung up on
expectations of having the most amount
of money or whatever just you know think
about it
um like I say where will you lose where
you live well you you know
um what matters you know uh your friends
your family your
um you know give a bed to a good bed to
sleep in for adequate food right out
into nature you know like uh my own view
is sometimes you know like the most
luxurious thing I can do is take a tent
and be out in a beautiful spot you know
um so
um
you know
avoid it uh you know no don't get
stretched out
you know understand it be prepared
redefining success and what happiness
means and what we should be aiming for
in life I think is a a very worthwhile
Pursuit right I'll tell you
um
this idea of success being
measured in the amount of money and
status you have is really screwed up
um
like if you think about money
and and this is uh com shown in measures
of happiness
um past the basic amount of money so
that you don't have uh the misery there
is no correlation between the level of
money you have and the level of
happiness you have
lots of studies show that
and the highest correlation
is do you have a community and that's
the highest source of
um
happiness and also it longevity it has a
big effect on longevities stress and
smoking more than stopping alcohol more
than going to the gym and exercising
right right
and so uh and then you think like what
is money for it has no intrinsic value
it only has a value of what it buys and
so
um it has a limited marginal ability you
benefit you you add more and more to it
and you know like what are you gonna do
okay so you're going to get a bigger
house or a bigger car or what what you
know okay
um and what does that really mean
incrementally relative to spending time
with friends and family and all of those
things you know most of the good things
in life are not expensive right
um friends family uh nature sex anything
you know it's not going to get better
with more money right material and
better and so
um it seems to me that
um it then can become an obsession
um and that's not healthy
so
I think it's you know by and large you
handle it well and it's all going to be
okay
um it's all gonna be okay
Ray dalio ladies and gentlemen if people
want to keep up to date with the work
that you're doing why should they go
um my more lengthy writings are on
LinkedIn but I'm on all of the social
media so
um in various ways and and when if I
write something that's longer
um it'll it'll be linked to uh LinkedIn
so you know all the major social media
I'm on
right I really appreciate you thank you
for today
thank you for your time what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]